sandra is a member of the navajo nation
and has worked as an engineer at sandia
national laboratories for 30 years
she earned her ms from stanford
university in structural engineering and
is the recipient of the 2021 women and
technology award from the
nm technology council
sandra's unique work focused on
providing technical assistance to u.s
tribes and she has mentored 44 technical
american indian and alaska native
college students
sandra so excited to get started and
take it away
thank you and welcome to everybody who's
joined us whatever time zone you're on
for me i'm coming uh on this
platform from albuquerque new mexico
as a member of the naval nation i wanted
to um talk a little bit more about my
background
with navajo traditions and navajo nation
is the largest tribe in the united
states
it covers three states the arizona new
mexico a little bit of utah area it's
one of the largest land-based tribes
there's also a very large in number
around 350 to 400 000
members of my tribe
but what i was taught by my dad who is a
tribal leader is that when you're asked
to talk in a public forum such as this
you need to talk a little bit more about
your credentials
because on navajo nation we don't just
let anybody get up and talk to an
audience in a public fashion you have to
explain a little bit more about yourself
so i did get a bachelor of science from
the university of mexico a master's
degree in structural engineering from
stanford and has been talked about i've
been an injured fair engineer for quite
a long time 33 years actually 30 years
at the current job that i have
you'll hear from what i'm going to tell
you is that i just enjoy my career
i've had very good
workings and wonderful managers great
people to work with but
you know every story is not always so
rosy as it appears but i wanted to at
least describe to you that at raised by
a matriarch my mom
navajo nation we are all about the women
the women lead the clans
all our inheritance is from our mother
i'm born of the
non-cheating clan the zuni clan of the
navajo and i was born as a gift to my
dad's clan the bitter water people
i was raised on the navajo nation close
very very close it's called a border
town a border to the navajo tribe itself
but every weekend
my dad was an official so i would be on
tribal lands every sunday
he had community meetings that he would
attend to
and i was outside as a young girl
running around and i think what i take
from that experience is to really
appreciate the natural beauty of where i
was raised the beautiful red rock
canyons of the gallup new mexico area my
home community is called church rock and
there's actually a rock because in the
southwest we have many rock formations
and that rock formation looks a little
bit like a church
and i think being descriptive of where
i'm from may be helpful to you because
we're very interested as tribal people
acknowledging our culture but we very
much acknowledge the places that we are
from
some babies when they're born you take
the umbilical cord and you bury that at
your home on the land on the tribal
lands on the reservation
and so for my dad he illustrated that as
although as a leader who lived in a
border town his umbilical cord his heart
his mind was attached to the church rock
area and he actually had to take his
case to the supreme court on navajo
nation and so that's how
i explain that it's so important to know
where i'm from
the conditions that i grew up with
my dad being a tribal leader he
instilled in me
being a leader at every chance i could
even though i didn't have to step up and
lead anything i was always taught to
listen a leader always listens
from my mom she was a public health
nurse for the indian health service all
of her career and from her i learned to
break different barriers
and so today i wanted to talk more about
the philosophy that i was taught as as a
young girl as a young woman
about the navajo philosophy of walking
in beauty
so it's not just one aspect of
physically walking and feeling
like you're beautiful that's that's too
simplistic it's your mind your thoughts
your being and all of you
takes on that
notion of doing things in a good way in
a positive way so when you walk in
beauty you're trying to leave a place
maybe even more beautiful than it was
through your speech through your actions
and you have to be able to do that in
different circumstance and so today
trying to explain this walking and
beauty path
that i've been on has been um
great and wonderful but there have been
some stumbling blocks so i'll focus a
little bit of
my talk on that and you can ask me any
questions about something that you hear
for my tribe in in being a matriarch in
a navajo i had to learn that when i went
into engineering i was into a
patrilineal world male dominated world
and i had to shift my thoughts into how
i fit into that
situation and it still has not changed
we don't have as many female leaders as
we could and should
so in another sense because i have
different duties beyond a researcher
beyond my work i am a
i've been appointed by the new mexico
governor to serve on my home institution
for my undergraduate work the university
of new mexico so i am one of the seven
trustees or regents that sets the policy
and performance and hiring of firing of
the president of the university of new
mexico and so that is a another layer of
leadership that i've been able to attain
because of my good work and
recommendations from others to the
governor and being recognized that and
approved by our
legislative body the governing body of
new mexico is also another uh point that
i wanted to make is that
as you try to do things in your career
hopefully you will be recognized for
that and then these opportunities will
start to open for you
but i i will say that
as you understand where you want to be
in life
you also have to
think how do you how do you impact what
what you're responsible for so in my job
as a i was a project engineer for a long
time
all internal customers to the laboratory
i work for
you know civil engineers we talk about
the infrastructure we talk about the
customer we talk about listening and how
much is it going to cost when is it
going to be done
all of that great career led to many
opportunities at my workplace
which culminated to working in strategic
planning with the president laboratory
director of where i work
and that's where i learned that leaders
get just as nervous as an everyday
person because we are people if anything
you've got to remember that you may have
a position to be a leader or something
in management as a as a director or as
you know first line manager but yet we
are people and we do get nervous when
it's
there's a lot of important meetings that
you're attending or presenting so that
was eye-opening for me that as a staff
member and i called myself a gopher
because i would go for this and go for
that as a staff member i didn't mind
because i was learning and observing
and being comfortable with who i am to
be able to work with top-notch leaders
and be confident in my work to support
them
but as a leader myself i'm also very
aware that i'm being
watched and i don't mean that in a bad
way but being observed
because another unique piece to to my
career
is if you take the u.s workforce that
are engineers
that are
born in the united states
i as a native woman engineer and one out
of 13 000
so my alma mater the university of new
mexico has a basketball arena that the
lower level seats about 13 000 people so
that's something i can visualize
if you put thirteen thousand u s
engineers in that arena i would be the
only woman who's a native american so
some people call that a double minority
um you're in a double bind um as far as
representing yourself in the workplace
and so i keep that number in my head
because when i feel like i'm
isolated or i'm alone or i don't see
people like me in what i do it's because
there aren't any and i have to admit
that it's
it's a very unique circumstance and
early in my career i was a little bit
uncomfortable with that
and and like i said the word isolated
came to mind but i had to learn how to
adapt how do you feel comfortable when
you are the only one and that's part of
where i hope you learn something from me
today is that instead of seeing that as
a negative i turn that
in that navajo philosophy to be
something i'm very proud of and i think
the other piece to that is that it lends
my um abilities my experience my
qualifications to be in very unique
circumstance
so the work that i do today working with
tribes across the united states
it's a very much a niche
i actually created the job for myself i
started out 20 years ago with a little
bit of seed money and i proved to the
sponsor from the federal government that
i was capable and able to do the job and
i could relate to tribal members on the
tribal lands to help them with renewable
energy projects so technical assistance
to the tribe was the base of where i got
my start
so over time it became a full-time
position
and over time i added more and more
funding by adding interns
the reason i chose to have interns and
right now i'm going to be close to the
50
person mark of interns that i'm working
with because i've got two year round
interns today and i'm hiring three
summer interns for in may we'll get
started full time so it's really close
to 50 interns over 20 years
i'm very proud of the fact that instead
of feeling isolated and alone in a low
budget
i understood that i could hire interns
very lower cost easily done i had 90
days to try to work with a student
now one of the things that i did
recognize is the students
are related to the science technology
engineering math fields
they're very um
selective in what they've chosen to
study and some people have said that i
cherry pick and um
you can say that but i'm trying to get
the native american students who are in
the stem fields to work with me for 90
days
and in that sense
i wasn't by myself i built my own team
and over these years i've been able to
follow their careers and i am so very
proud of the different interns that i've
had including
nora cata who's online today and i thank
her profusely for having me get to know
that the people who put on this forum to
be able to talk to you today
i will acknowledge that because of what
i do today i've
about a year ago i've been invited to be
a part of the women's committee at the
national academy and so this is the u.s
national academy of
science engineers and medicine
and there's a woman's committee that
covers all of those uh
national academies focused in on
different areas
and there i
i'm just amazed at the women that are on
this committee
there's such at a
key point in their career many have been
the only one in their fields of study
for a long time and they become leaders
in different fashion maybe not a
management leader but a thought leader
an action leader by all that they've
done and so being a part of that group
is a very key honor in my mind but one
thing we talked about is topics that we
could cover in this next year
and the way i i described it as i would
like women
who are at the higher ranks to tell
their stories
that comes back to my navajo traditions
of how do i tell you about what i've
done in my career
rather than a powerpoint presentation
i'd rather just be here today and tell
you my story and tell you in a way that
hopefully you can relate to
and ask more questions of me
so what i've described to the committee
is i want people to tell their story
for native americans that's a way to
communicate that they're very
comfortable with and what's interesting
is it's not a part of the way that
science math engineering technology
medicine
is used to sharing information
even the word sharing is
can be a very um
generic way that women use and i'm a
woman so i'm going to use that word
sharing that's how i convey information
is by sharing that we get used to the
language that we talk about amongst each
other that we don't have to you know be
in our patrilineal workplace and
communicate the way the way it's
expected but we get to communicate the
way that we would like and in the form
and fashion that we want
and so one of the ideas i've been trying
to get more people to understand is that
we've talked a long time about glass
ceilings where you're only able to rise
up and get
through the ranks to a point where
you're acknowledged in your career for
your work by breaking that ceiling that
you don't just see what's above you and
it's clear you can see it but you can't
get there because that glass is in the
way
well i want to tell you today that
i've broken many glass ceilings but yet
what i did not expect and what i would
love for you to ask about is i'm
actually finding shards of glass that
have come and cut me
and this is not physically cut but
mentally emotionally um
dialogues that
i get into conversations that i don't
expect some negativity that i've
received
it's like so when you break something
there's actually some byproduct
which could be
hurtful it could be toxic if you let it
and what i'd love to just understand is
that
that we as women
i have a natural tendency to be
nurturing i'm not going to say all women
are but there's a natural tendency to
help to assist
to help grow to
to lead and i deliberate with the word
nurture
that if i acknowledge that something's
happening to me of that nature of shards
of glass
that maybe you can relate to what i'm
saying
um i've had comments when i was early in
my career of
well why do you get that assignment
i'll give you an example i was given an
assignment corporately for the whole
laboratory to
study a child care center for our
laboratory for all the new employees
that were having children that maybe
that would help them
to give some support to them as far as a
place to bring their children and then
it would be right near work or right
near where they worked
and there were many women that actually
said to me oh sandra you got that
assignment because you're planning a
child care center for you when you have
children
and i thought
no that is not the reason i have this
assignment
the reason i have this assignment
because i asked for it i want to benefit
for all people at the lab
maybe it's women with young children
maybe it's the men who have new children
i want them to have this resource and by
the way i do not have children i've
decided in my career in my life not to
have children so having somebody turn
something that i thought was a beautiful
and interesting assignment to making it
like i did it personally for my own gain
is one of the shards of glass that i
have an example to tell you it's just
not right and at the time i didn't
i didn't confront the person with the
way i felt but as i thought about it not
very analytical i thought later why did
that bother me so much and i had to
really attribute that to
misunderstanding
um people aren't understanding that i as
a project manager and as an engineer
take on all kinds of assignments you
can't always make it so personal and
internal to you as a personal gain that
was never the case
i think the others with my role as a
regent or trustee at the university of
mexico we have public meetings every
other month
and there was a point where we had some
public comment that was
in my mind a little too derogatory of
our president who is the first
president women president that we've
ever had in our 100 plus year history of
our institution
and i didn't appreciate that they were
um
commenting on what kind of car she drove
what kind of necklace she had
claiming that her pearl necklace that
she was wearing that day was like she
was above everybody she was touching her
pearls
in a fashion that she was just thinking
about the students and the faculty and
staff as
you know minions or peons and i i think
that's the word they use and i thought
that's not right so when i had a chance
to comment back i said you know what
i wear a necklace usually and if i was
to touch my necklace it would not be
saying i have this and you don't have
that it's remember i was given this gift
by one of my relatives because she knows
that i do public speaking that i do
presentations and it reflects my native
culture very beautifully
and that's the way i would wear this
necklace not to say i have this and you
don't have that
mary many crazy misunderstandings that
are subtle but
very much unappreciated and i'll have to
let you know that you you have to
understand
anytime you have a confrontation when
you have a negative situation you put
your personal energy into that
and over time i've learned i'm not going
to fight every fight it maybe it's not
even my fight
and i have to think about it do i have
the personal energy
is this relationship important to me
is this a random colleague or this a
stranger that has said something to me
is it worth my effort is it worth
something for that people to learn about
what they should think differently to
not misinterpret me and who i am
or is it just let it go because it's not
that important and i've had to do that
many times because i just don't want to
get into conversations like that with
everybody especially strangers i'm not
here to educate you know someone who's
misunderstanding but in a forum like
this i am more than willing to do that
to help clarify who i am what i do and
why i do it
and that that's part of i think
taking on that positivity of walking in
beauty and conversations that you have
the other i would say walking in beauty
for me is giving good quality to the
work that i do
because i work with tribes across the
united states in various avenues i am so
respectful of those leaders
because many times they've been in a
position that they've been appointed or
they've been elected but they choose to
serve
and there's appreciation for me
and that experience is probably from my
father he was an elected official and he
had to put up with a lot of negativity
and so if i can be a positive force to
help them solve a community problem i'm
more than willing to do that
i think that's a part of where i really
love to understand what people need as
far as solutions
i will have to say there's a balance you
have to strike so
i left the lab for about a year three
years i intended not to go back i had
gotten my dream job or my dream at the
time
was
running a non-profit that helped me grow
as a student as a native american in
science and technology and this was the
american indian science and engineering
society the acronym is aces
you can look that up on their website
and i'll put it in the chat if if you'd
like a-i-s-e-s dot o-r-g
but that's organization that i belong to
and what was so unique about that and my
why i gave so much time and effort is
because they never put anything in front
of me that was a block or a hindrance
there was no glass ceiling in that
organization for me i could go at the
top level of what i wanted to do to help
that organization and i thought about it
and i wanted to be the executive reader
the executive degree leader for that
organization called the executive
director
and i got the job and i was a national
spokesperson so i was speaking all the
time with corporations about diversity
how do you increase women in the
workplace how do you support
underrepresented minorities in the in
the united states i got to travel to new
zealand and meet maori folks
just wonderful opportunities for me to
grow and to grow as a person and gain
all different types of insights in
working with people in very different
cultures even though tribal communities
may seem
homogeneous they're not every tribe has
a very different culture
and many have very distinct languages
and distinct histories
so it was insightful for me to be at the
top job of what i thought i could do and
the rest of my career retire from that
but lo and behold i gave everything to
that job and i i hate to say this but
sometimes we as women
give too much to our jobs give too much
to the work
give of ourselves to a point that i
wound up in the emergency room
i had given every ounce of energy to
that organization and my body said no
i came down very ill got hit with all
kinds of
cold and flu because my immunities were
down i gave everything to the job
and i'll give you one evidence today
my
complexion is a lot lighter so i'm
navajo i'm full-blooded navajo but i was
browner at that time because i became so
anemic it took some of the color out of
my face
and so it's interesting that over time
to reflect on that is
sandra you cannot keep doing this
because it could harm your health and
look this is what the deities have shown
you you're going to be a little bit
lighter in complexion because of all
that you gave at them one point in time
and the lesson was learned
don't do that again there's always a
balance between your work
your home life your relationships that
you just cannot let work
have everything of you you've gotta say
no and i've learned that over time and
you'll have to learn to do that too
the other is opportunities will come to
you as you gain
experience and
you've got good credentials and you've
got a great incredible reputation
you'll be sought out but you cannot take
every opportunity and you're going to
have to be a more more strategic in your
thinking
so i'm going to leave with a little bit
of how do you how do you do strategic
planning for yourself
i had a very wonderful mentor his name
is don coyas k
excuse me c-o-y-i-s don
he created a non-profit for native
american people to become sober
as you might know now you will know
there's a lot of alcoholism and drug
addiction on our tribal lands because of
the lack of hope the lack of opportunity
and many do not have the education that
i had i was able to obtain and if you
don't have education to
further your career further your life
sometimes you're held back by that and
you have very dire economic development
and family situations and you don't have
as much hope as you might have if you've
had opportunities
and to understand from don and his
philosophy
he taught me as a young undergraduate
student that it's going to be hard the
stem fields are hard being a
only person who looks like me in a field
with
white males is going to be hard
and so acknowledge that but also get a
vision of where you want to go
so he clearly taught me he said do you
know where you want to work and i said i
think i know he says so it where is that
i said the lawrence livermore national
labs in livermore california he says
that's very specific good for you i said
i know because i visited there and i
thought it was a great place to work
okay you know what it looks like picture
that in your head what does the sky look
like what does the landscape look like
what time of year is it what does it
smell like and for me california smell
the air smell sweet because you have so
much moisture in the air and the grass
was green because this time of the year
there's a lot of rain that happened
in the spring i mean yeah in the winter
now spring you have beautiful hills of
green green grass and wildflowers i
could picture that because i've seen it
and there i am walking to the building
where i would work and i on my trip my
field visit i said where would a civil
engineer work at this laboratory they
said here's the building plant
engineering we take care of the
infrastructure
and so i have that vision he says there
you are your first day what's in your
hands i said i've got my purse i've got
my mechanical pencil i have my
calculator because that's what engineers
do we carry that around with us and i
said i'm going to carry my lunch because
i know i'm going to have student loans i
have to pay off so i've got to watch my
money he's all that is clear to you walk
in the building and sit down at your
desk and you're going to start work
that's how clear you need to have a
vision of where you're going to have a
future foothold
in either a job or a career
because when things go wrong
when your health goes down
you have to create that image in your
mind so that you get through what you're
going through now the pitfall the whole
the boulder you can't get around
that vision will help you get to that
point so that you're very clear of where
you want to get
now your vision may change over time but
that's okay that's the way things should
be in your life you grow and you change
i'll give you one of my first bosses he
said you know what sandra you need to
learn to talk about your work with
with your co-workers okay
next you need to talk to me about your
work i said okay i thought you were
observing you kind of knew what i was
doing that he says yes i'm observing but
i want you to tell me about your work
by the way now you need to talk to other
managers about your work oh and you need
to talk to
upper level people about your work i had
no idea but it all had to do with
performance management appraisals they
need to know who you are what you do
short and snappy don't talk their ear
off but they have to be aware
because at that point in your career
you're being viewed as how great a
performer you are how might you be
rewarded with a bonus how much raise you
might get
based on your communication your
performance appraisal written material
knowledge of what your work is about and
so i had that as a great learning i had
no idea nobody taught me that so i'm
telling you today you've got to talk
about your work with people who have
influence on evaluating your performance
last i'm going to leave off with
thinking about how to take care of
yourself so
you must not overdo things you've got to
take your days off you've got to rest
i'm learning on the weekends i just to
rest and i cannot push push push
with all these activities that people
want me to be involved with
i i have to say no because my body at my
age i have to give it time to recuperate
and so even getting ready for today i
had a little bit of morning meetings but
i deliberately went to bed early because
i needed to be
energetic and and on my best
showing of what i can do in this forum
today and so planning ahead for these
things
does you
a world of difference eating right
drinking enough water some of these
things are basic but i'm here to remind
you they're very very important you have
got to take care of yourself
the other illustration i'll give you and
leave with you is if you're an airplane
and the oxygen comes down and you're
supposed to be getting your oxygen
don't help others help yourself first
put the oxygen mask on yourself
then you can help others
otherwise you're going to pass out
because you didn't put your oxygen mask
on so that's another illustration for me
it's important for you to take care of
yourself if you don't you can't help
take
care of others you have to be good at
taking care of yourself
and i guess i will leave off right there
and i'm hoping we have a whole variety
of questions so thank you and i look
forward to look forward to your
questions
sandra thank you so much for that we do
have a variety of questions i
was listening so intently on what you
were saying
and i would come up with a question
myself in the middle of when you were
talking and then you would answer it
right after that and there's well
there's so many things that that would
be so helpful to just just take another
look at
um
a couple of things that you said that
really stuck with me is um you mentioned
a mentor you had don coyas
he helped you with some strategic
planning it sounded like for your
overall career
and you mentioned your manager and how
he said you need to talk more about your
work and you know around the
organization be snappy but but do it
um
did you feel supported by
you know you have some mentors but did
you feel supported by your male
colleagues
in your efforts to improve minority
representation in stem while you were
going through your career you've
mentioned a couple of of mentors but but
did you also have that support
i did i i'm i'll just say i'm lucky i
don't think everybody is lucky um
but aside from that that's important but
what you need to really shore up for
yourself is to have personal mentors
that are not work related so my mom was
my first mentor as a working mother she
went back for her bachelor of science in
nursing when i was little that's a great
example she's the first one in our
family to get a higher education degree
uh the the other i think would be um
i got to meet mary ross and mary ross
was the first native american um
scientist engineer rocket scientist
she's featured on a gold coin of the us
that's how important she is and mary i
got to talk with her and she almost made
it to her 100th birthday
so again how fortunate and blessed have
i been in my career to have the first
native american woman scientist engineer
to be my mentor i mean that's just gold
right there and she's on a gold coin
i think the other is henrietta mann dr
henry yet a man
wonderful cheyenne
woman who's very cultural she learned
she helped me to learn
to be graceful
graceful in the way i talk graceful in
the way i communicate with people
how i am around others
always do it with grace don't think
yourself too much and don't get a big
head just be grateful for what you have
and try to assist
now i i just had my 30-year mark at
sandia and i gave credit to all the
managers that i've had at sandia they
have all been very very helpful to me
i even got to see a manager that left
our lab and he was at a conference two
weeks ago
paul beers was my manager and he helped
get my promotion to principal member of
the technical staff what does that mean
there's a four-rung ladder of um nerds
and i'm on the third run of four
and i'm realistic i think you need to be
realistic about your career i'm never
gonna make distinguished
you have to have a lot of research
a lot of credentials and that's just not
me
i love my master's degree that's all i
wanted i just want to get to work
if i need to write a paper i will but
that's not the way i've done my career
it's not by writing paper after paper
and i have a few published just because
it's interesting work
i like to do i'm out there in
communities they know me
i have strategic plans that i help with
and then five years later they have
hardware grants to get solar panels in a
very isolated alaska village because of
what i've been able to help with
and i will say you know mentors
internally
i'm a 20-year overnight success i think
it's the only way to say it
i've been doing this work for 20 years
right now it's like we need to work with
communities we need to work communities
in need the us we have a lot of energy
justice and people who want to get their
energy costs lowered as a community and
it's like
i've been doing that a long time i'll
tell you and they really want to know my
secret and i just tell them basically
you've got to learn to build trust with
people
well how do you do that it's like well
that's the secret sauce you're gonna
have to learn how to build trust with
people i can't teach that to you so
that's how i've been mentored
and it also
you know sandra i'm so struck when you
speak because you
to me you speak in
you're very very illustrative
and so when you speak i see a
an image kind of like you said when you
were describing to don and he kept
asking you
what does it smell like what does it
look like what do you have in your
pocket and so
not only you know along the way but i
can see how you have incorporated that
in the way that you speak and it's it's
a pleasure to have conversation with you
because
we're not only speaking but also my
brain is seeing things so
thank you for that
um
and that's the that's the nature of
storytelling
and i i learned that when i began public
speaking because i'm a i'm a natural
introvert
so
this type of forum is okay because i'm
not in front of a live audience if i am
i have to psych up for it get my mind
mentally there and if the hardest thing
for me is like um what they call a meet
and greet with strangers
it takes a lot of energy for me to do
that i'll do it but afterwards i need to
be by myself because i've used all that
energy to connect with people i don't
know
and then i need to be quiet
so you got to learn that about yourself
of how you communicate and what do
what's best for you
and i think that's a great segue so we
we had a question from laura
um she said i think a lot of us are
tired of the mental energy it takes to
continually break glass ceilings so to
be in a room and network but also to
break glass ceilings how do you find the
energy to keep going and fighting the
good fight this is interesting to me and
when is it okay to sit back and rest she
goes on to say i'm particularly
interested in your perspective as
informed by the navajo tradition
so a lot of it has to do with
how does it affect people around me
how might it affect my relatives you
know let's say the way i put it in in
the workplace is that you know some of
this sexual harassment that women go
through it that they shouldn't have to
but
it
the way i tell gentlemen about this
white males is that just think about it
i'm telling you what happened to me now
what would you think now if you don't
know me very well but i've experienced
this
you would think differently if this
happened to your daughter in the
workplace you would totally have a
different reaction
in how you would see that situation
because now it's personal now it's your
offspring if it was your wife it was
your cousin
that really drives it home that this is
not right
how do you make it right
and i have to i have to go back to
analyze the situation for what is in it
to keep as a relationship
if it's just somebody off the street and
they want to argue with you i will walk
away because i don't know you and what
you're trying to push on me and that's
the other thing some of this information
that people want to get and aggravate
the situation it's them it's about them
it's not about me
they have some stigma about native women
or something that is not me that's like
your thing to deal with don't don't push
it on me
i'm not here to inform you about every
nuance
i'm just trying to help you understand
that we're able to be in the workplace
in society
and be understanding of we all try to
contribute you you as a colleague
contribute so
you have to also understand how much
energy if it's your colleague you're
going to have to give it some energy
because you might not be able to get out
of that work group you may not be able
to
leave the
company and i will tell you at one point
being sexually harassed on the job i had
to leave the company there was no out
for me
i didn't want to fight i
my mom had just passed away i had just
graduated from stanford university
i had just gotten married all these
personal circumstance and then people
said you need to fight this you need to
have a lawsuit it's like uh-uh
i'm hurting personally i got a lot going
on i'm not taking that fight i would
have won
well i wasn't ready for it so i left
the way i jokingly say this indian had
to get out of dodge city
it's no way i'm not going to fight that
they were never going to change
sometimes you're going to meet people
it's their issue they are never going to
change no matter how much you try to
educate them that's the time to just
walk away
i have felt the same i have done the
same
i have walked away from a situation that
could have been
um not with um sexual harassment but
walking away from everyone saying to me
surely you're going to go to court over
this
actually i'm not i'm not going to do
that i'm not i can't i can't expend that
energy so that i really really felt that
deeply and also everything else that you
have going on it's it's not it's not a
one track you said you know you just
gotten married your mom had just passed
on like that's a lot so a lot thank you
for that
um a question
another point that
i don't dwell on that negativity
otherwise you'd see this big old chip on
this shoulder and i've met many women
who that chip is pretty hard and rock
hard and i tell them you're giving so
much energy to keeping that on your
shoulder when you could expend that
energy on improving yourself
helping others helping young people
helping your kids helping grandkids
don't hang on to that it takes too much
of energy to hang on let it go
and i'm having to work on some of that
let it go
it doesn't do me any
we had a comment come in asking how do
you move beyond the shards it sounds
like you're telling us about it right
now
you have to
you have to become
[Music]
you have to let it go
and it can it it can take you know years
to do that sometimes but i think it's
about wanting
yes
yeah
um
shazia had a question she said you
talked about negativity that we face on
daily basis the daily basis so where did
you find the most negativity from your
own community or outside and why do you
think that's the case
oh my gosh
it's the least the one you expect the
least so it was this one job
i was being sexually harassed by two
minority gentlemen i don't men they're
not even gentlemen one was my classmate
i'll just say that
hispanic i didn't expect that from a man
of color
and then there was a tribal member
male it's like the least i expected was
from them to do this to me one of their
own
but it turns out they could not
mentally
see me as a brown woman in the workplace
other than
somebody to be used an object a woman
whatever that's the way they viewed
women especially brown women it's like
you got some serious issues guys but
that's not me
and i i i reacted
i deliberately did not look good in the
workplace i didn't wear my makeup i
didn't take care of my hair i didn't
wear nice clothes because i thought if i
if i minimize myself
and and they don't see me they'll stop
it didn't stop and what happened to me i
felt ugly i didn't want to go to work i
didn't feel good about myself i didn't
do my work because i didn't feel right
and so that's what i mean don't take it
on you it's them
and if they're never going to change i
needed to get away from them
and you know years later they told me
briefly something happened to them they
had some disciplinary actions like
well
whatever i've moved on from that
right you just removed yourself from the
situation because you can only yeah i
mean you're you're in you're going to
that work environment you're not feeling
good they're there no matter you you
have already bent so much by changing
your appearance and doing other things
at some point you just have to walk away
definitely that's how bad we can get
that's how bad it can get yeah
okay
changing gears a little bit rosanna asks
do you believe that intuition is
important when it comes to decision
making
or
should we analyze carefully important
life decisions like changing our career
paths so you had don he talked about
strategic planning do you also feel like
intuition comes a little bit in there or
what do you think about that
oh i think you need to do both because
you've got a brain and you've got a
heart right you're logically trying to
figure out what's going to work best
how's that all going to come about
i analyze things to death but then at
the point i have to say not just heart
but what's it what's in my stomach you
know if it if something hits in your
stomach in a bad way
you that's an alarm for yourself
something's not right it's it's making
me sick literally
that's your intuition or you know i
don't i don't feel right i don't i feel
stressed i
it doesn't seem like this is the way i
should be going that's a feeling and you
have to trust that
and maybe i got that from my mom being
my mom was very direct um
she just was trying to teach me quickly
she died when she was only 55 i think
she knew she wasn't going to live that
long
so she was really straightforward with
me you know you've chosen a really tough
profession it's
all there are men in that profession
engineer civil is a rough
crowd
you need to hold yourself up
hard and and then don't be afraid you
need to be as tough as your fingernail
she can say that but the situations it
was hard and you know they pierced my
fingernail at time it hurt
but you have to try to say okay mom said
these days would come as they some songs
say and you
move yourself forward i think having a
support system and however you create
that is very very important
i will say if you have a goal of vision
be very careful with who you share that
with
because i don't want what happened to me
is i shared it with somebody i thought
it was close with but they said
oh my you're really ambitious aren't you
you really think that's going to happen
huh
wow you think a lot of yourself was like
wow that's not what i want to hear
i want you to say hey that sounds
interesting i you could probably do that
you'd have to get experience here and
there and there
so be careful
share it with somebody who's going to
give you good feedback not be jealous or
whatever that thing is they have about
you you don't need that
and the way i talk about this with
younger
women and students is that that
character eeyore and we need a poop
there are ers out there that you've got
to get away from
they wear a cloud over their head their
ears are always down they even talk
negative they talk
is it a good day oh it's not a good day
i mean you can probably point to
somebody in your life who's an eeyore
you need to minimize your time with that
person because you're going to start
having your ears come down you're going
to start talking like that you're going
to say oh you're right it's not sunny
today it's like what the sun's going to
come out pretty soon you you need that
positivity around you stay away from the
e-wars
you heard it here first i mean that's
i got probably four takeaways during
that last answer i was typing away
furiously you said do both you have a
brain and a heart not just a heart do
what's in your stomach and i love i love
er so if you're wondering if you need a
quick gut check when you're around
somebody how do i feel could this
potentially be me you are i think that's
great advice thank you
so many great questions coming in sandra
um
a dt asked
do you try to bring some of the navajo
philosophies to other aspects of your
work and social commitments if so can
you please give some examples
sure i maybe commit way too much
um
so i
people thought at the board of regents
that i wanted to be the president of the
board of regents
which yeah at one time i wanted to be
but
um
that's not me right now what i wanted to
be was a secretary treasurer because my
name will be on every diploma at the
university of new mexico the gay is a
traditional navajo name and there was a
navajo
part of the administration that signed
off on your diploma i'm a part of that
official process
a woman of color signed your diploma
that's how i deliberately looked for
something of that nature to
make my stamp literally on that document
i think the other is um
i give to every aces organization
function i can fit in american indian
science in engineering society i can't
do them all but i love giving back to
them
you know indirectly
people around me are very observant so i
have cousins so my cousins we pull
closer so my women cousins are like my
sisters
so their daughters
could be my second cousins but i think
of them as my nieces i have four of my
nieces my cousins daughters that are
engineers i didn't take any of them
aside i didn't twist any arms i don't
even think i talked to them that much
about engineering you know this the
curriculum is where you should go this
is what you study none of that
but they're all working engineers right
now because they saw what i was doing i
enjoy my job and um
it was an educational path that would
open up a wonderful career for them
they're doing really well
what an example what an example for your
whole family thank you for sharing that
earlier you had said sandra communicate
in the way that you want not in the way
that the patrilineal workplace expects
a question that we had come in is as a
manager or a leader
how can you make those you lead to feel
comfortable community and communicating
in the way they want
rather than the way the petrol linear
workplace expects
you're going to do that by leading by
example
you may have to say okay this meeting
i want you and this is team building
right
i want you to tell me a story about your
life
where you know pick a subject and then
go around the table and let people tell
their story and you'll find out how
people want to communicate it may be
very detailed story like engineers it
was blue green and then turned black
and then it was round and it was square
that's fine that's the way they
communicate
but then you'll have somebody different
who will tell you more about the
relationships that was in the situation
and how this didn't go right this didn't
this went great and they'll get excited
they might have their hands that's how
you bring out natural communication is
by something that is a little bit more
informal
then you start testing the waters by
providing that example in your own
management chain saying
i know you want me to present a
powerpoint today but i wanna i'll give
you a powerpoint for the record but let
me just tell you what's going on with my
project and then you get into details i
my boss came to me and said
um i told him i'm going to muscular
apache for three days down southern new
mexico we're doing a strategic energy
plan with the tribal council okay check
the box he knew
on that saturday of the week we finished
on friday on saturday he calls me on my
cell phone sandra i heard on npr that
the mescalero apache are gonna do a
future based on renewable energy
possibly wind possibly solar
i said yeah tony
i know how do you know i thought you
might be interested i said tony
i was there we did a 90-day action plan
with the tribe and one of their actions
was communicate the goals of this
session to whoever you want whoever you
think is important they got a hold of
npr
he heard the story it came back to me
it's like
yes we did what we were supposed to do
action a lot of action
a lot of action
and also i really like that how someone
asked for something you can give it for
the record but you also get to
communicate in the way that you want
that it works best for you
because sometimes when we go into
something and i've experienced this as
well this really at home is
you know it's not going to hit the mark
if you do it in that way you just know
in your gut and so you you can give them
what they want but you can also
change it so thank you thank you it felt
like permission from sandra honestly
really
thank you um this kicks off some
questions about um mentoring which i
know that you have a rich history in
also with um our nora
so
do you have any advice for people
looking to get started and mentoring or
hiring interns
what was your process how do you fit
this work into your core
responsibilities how do you find your
interners and mentees so just all kinds
of questions so if you could just talk
to us about that that would be wonderful
sure
you got to be creative and think outside
the box so did anybody tell me interns
were easy to hire no
i figured that out i was in a in in a
project that i'm i'm not an electrical
engineer i am not i don't know solar
so what do you do you surround yourself
with people who know more than you do
right that's another
nuance that i've learned so i went
searching for
this gal i read in a book winona leduc
is a famous native american activist she
wrote a book called all my relations in
there and that is a chapter on debbie
taywa
install solar on the hopi reservation in
arizona she's an installer she's an
electrician i thought that's who i need
to work with i need to debbie i need you
to teach me not to electrocute myself
yeah that's the bottom line and she
happened to be in school at the time and
i said debbie let me hire you come work
with me i need help you're the right
person you're the exact person i need so
i sought her out then it became
oh
maybe i could have a job description and
lo and behold the energy policy act
defined the mission of indian energy to
have provide technical assistance help
further the inner indian goals of each
tribe
and capacity building human capacity
building well to me that's an intern
i'm going to build up the capacity of a
young person who could possibly be a
leader
could possibly work
above me
and he does tommy jones was one of my
interns now he's my federal sponsor for
my work
i'm growing my own so that's what i'm
looking for
and you find how do you keep that a
niche
in my applications i have an essay that
i have them answer that weeds out a lot
because quite frankly folks if you're
going to read a job posting
answer what's in the job posting don't
just say i looked at it i've asked for
five essays and i see this resume
there's no answers to any questions it's
like you didn't read the job posting did
you so that screens out a lot of people
right there
and then when i read it it's like i need
to know this about you i need to know
that and then when i do have a in in
person or video interview then i ask
more in-depth questions you only have 90
days to work with me and what do you
think you're going to be able to get out
of this internship program
what do you bring to the table because
we're i'm
swimming as fast as i can in the deep
end of the water i'll help you if you
need a light preserver but i need you to
perform at that level too
so that's kind of my expectation and
that i've set
excellent so
if you had to
share with the audience if you had to
share with the audience
three things that you're always looking
for in an intern or a mentee they don't
have to be the most important they just
have to be three things that you're
always looking for what what are those
things
i need to see an objective in your
resume
i don't just i don't just want a
template what is your objective is it
written for that job or is it a generic
one you need to write it for the job
tailor it to that job posting the others
i need to know beyond your academics
how have you given back to the community
are you part of a student organization
have you done
um the houses for humanity where you did
some construction if you're a civil
engineer and you did that kind of thing
that's helpful you know how to use a
hammer nail although engineers don't
always do that but we have to know how
to put things together and then i think
the third is
you know be honest if some things
happened i mean just say i took off a
year due to family obligations and
illness and leave it at that that way
when i look at your transcripts there's
a hole right there you already filled a
hole
then i can move beyond that and say sure
it's a great candidate
don't bury things i don't you don't have
to be blunt but you can be very good in
summarizing
here's what happened don't get into
details but i moved beyond that and now
i'm back in school full time
i agree i think there's a lot there too
about owning
where you've been because it
you know contributed to where to where
you are now
so i think you know don't try to bury it
or you know sideswipe but just as you
said just come come with it
um
we have a couple of more minutes left
and i have a couple of questions here
that i think that we would be
um
i think that we need to hear from you on
sure
here it's clear there is a strength in
your commitment to walking beauty that
comes from the navajo identity
can you talk a bit about that and what
are some ways that we can find that kind
of strength when we don't have such a
strong concept of balance in our own
cultural backgrounds and traditions
i think you can learn from multiple
cultures in the world if you pick navajo
you know go to the websites that talk
about it it's a holistic approach so
some people think about it that way um
it's all around you there's a prayer
that we have that's walking in beauty
you have a ceremony but it's the notion
of
you're going forward you leave beauty on
the sides of you behind you above you
you're conscious of yourself in the
world you're not just here doing one
thing you're a whole person being a part
of a system whether it's the earth your
community your school even in your own
household
are you doing things in a positive way
that's a philosophy that i think you can
take a hold of
um i hope that's in straightforward
enough
excellent excellent and i think this one
and this will be our last question here
and it links firmly in with that sandra
have you experienced dissonance between
cultural tradition tradition and strong
female
leadership
and if so
how did you navigate that
i built a reputation of good work so if
you didn't think i was going to be good
at it as a woman well i'm going to prove
you wrong i'm a very good worker i know
what i know um i'll learn to communicate
the way you want me to but i'm giving
you everything i got if you can't see me
for me
then i need to do things so you say hey
she's got black hair and brown skin it's
not going to change
she's a good person to do the job i
think that's the bottom line get build
that reputation of a good worker a good
person um somebody you want to be around
sandra i think i speak for everyone here
who can't speak right now because
they're muted but
you are someone we all want to be around
thank you thank you so much for spending
this hour here with us for going to bed
early last night for fitting in your day
for making room for us it was such a
pleasure um for everyone who joined us
today thank you so much for being here
if you're watching this later um as a
recording
thank you for being with us here today
digitally um sandra it was such a
pleasure
thank you again everyone signing off
from stanford
thank you
you